okay so in this livestream what we're
going to do is we're going to talk about
the ECT specifically the math section
and we're going to do is we're going to
first talk a little bit about complex
numbers imaginary numbers usually this
is just like maybe one question on the
AC T but it's an easy one to get right
if you understand the concepts so we'll
go through that first and then I'm going
to open it up for questions and we can
talk about things that you want to
discuss in this in this live stream so
as people are just joining us now can
you let me know can you hear me okay are
able to hear me on this live stream okay
everyone so if you can just let me know
in the chat so what we'll do is we'll
start off by talking about some complex
numbers so first thing we want to
basically understand is you know I okay
which represents you an imaginary number
and that's a equal to the square root of
negative one so when you work with
complex numbers complex numbers they're
part real and part imaginary so you've
got a plus bi okay so it's a plus bi
form so the a is the real part right and
the bi is the imaginary part oh Jessie
good morning thanks for joining us can
you hear me okay can you hear me okay
okay and then the B part is the
imaginary portion of it so again we're
just talking a little bit about okay
great okay so you can hear me good okay
so basically you know we're just talking
about how to work with complex numbers
as they sometimes occur on that math
section of the AC T and so we're just
going to go through just some simple
examples here and then we'll open up for
questions and now we can discuss things
you want to talk about so first of all
let's look at some examples so say for
example if you have 3 plus 2i minus 4
minus 5i so what you want to do here is
you know it's just like working with
polynomials where you add and subtract
polynomials but what you can do here
when you subtract subtraction is really
like adding the opposite so notice I
just change these to the opposite sign
and then all you have to do is go ahead
and not combine like terms so we've got
3 plus negative 4 which is
negative 1 & 2 I plus 5 I which is 7 I
so adding and subtracting complex
numbers pretty simple but when you start
getting into some a little bit more
challenging ones say for example with
let's say when you're multiplying and
dividing let's take a look at some of
those so say for example if you had the
same problem 3 plus 2i but now it's
times 4 minus 5i so again this is just
like a binomial times a binomial so what
you want to do is you just want to foil
so you're going to take the first terms
or you can distribute 3 times 4 which is
12 outer terms which is going to give
you negative 15 I okay then the inner
terms 2i times 4 which gives you a tie
and then 2i times negative 5i which is
the negative 10 is squared all right and
the key thing to remember is where we
talked about this earlier but I is equal
to square root of negative 1 but I
squared is equal to negative 1 okay so
when you see I squared just replace that
with what it equals negative 1 and
negative 1 times negative 10 is going to
give us a positive 10 right so now all
we have to do is combine like terms so
12 plus 10 is giving us 22 and negative
15 I plus 8i is giving us negative 7i
and so that's it so adding subtracting
multiplying not too bad now let's go
over to dividing now so dividing what
you want to do is let's look at the same
problem 3 plus 2i
okay / 4 minus 5i you don't want this I
in the denominator that's considered
improper so what you want to do is you
want to multiply by what's called the
complex conjugate okay so what is the
complex conjugate well it's the same two
terms that we have here in the
denominator but we're going to change
this to 4 plus 5i so you change that
sign in between you know from
subtracting to adding if this was adding
and you'd make this in between
subtracting right but whatever you do to
the denominator you want to do to the
numerator because if you think about it
anything divided by itself is is 1 so
when you multiply by this fraction
you're going to get you're not going to
get the anything different it's just
gonna be in a different format okay so
now what I'm going to do is just go
ahead and foil these together but let's
do the denominators first so we've got
4 times 4 which is 16 4 times 5 which is
20 I negative 5i times 4 which is
negative 20 I so notice that those
cancel each other out and then negative
5i times positive 5 I which is negative
25 I squared but remember I squared is
equal to negative 1 times negative 25
makes this actually equal to positive 25
so 16 plus 25 gives us 41 for our
denominator so let me just put that over
here so for the numerator we're gonna do
the same thing we're to distribute 3
times 4 is 12 3 times 5i gives us 15 I
right and then that 2i times 4 gives us
8 i and 2i times 5i gives us 10 I
squared whoops
10 I squared all right ok I squared is
negative 1 times 10 is negative 10 plus
12 is 2 okay so I'll just put that up
here and then 15 i plus 8i is 23 i so
our final answer you can see is 2 + 23 i
/ 41 and again our whole goal is to get
rid of the I in the denominator so
that's just a little preview of you know
working with complex numbers as they
sometimes occur on the AC T so usually
there's just like one question but it's
good to just familiarize yourself with
that concept so when you see it you're
not throwing off-guard
so at this point I think what I'll do is
open it up to you know the live stream
and the chat and we can talk about
questions that you want to talk about so
what do you think everyone's getting
ready for the AC T on Saturday so things
you want to talk about questions that
you have regarding the AC T what do you
think well one thing I wanted to mention
is that you know I did put together
about six months ago or so I put
together what I call the huge AC t--
math review video course and basically
what I do in that video course is I go
through 65 concepts that you want to
know for the AC T definitely a
important constant that you want to know
to boost your score and things that are
covered on on most every test almost
every test and so that's a valuable
resources if you're looking for more
things to practice or you just want to
get get some kind of insider view on
what you should know for the test you
can check that out and I've got a link
in the description to this to this video
so if you go into the description you'll
see you'll see the link there and
there's some free preview so you can
check it out see if it's something
that's right for you but what do you
think you have some questions some
things that you want to talk about right
now things you want to ask me the more
things that you guys ask me I think the
more that everyone will you know benefit
from so I maybe you can let me know what
you guys want to talk about and we can
we can jump into it so what do you think
so is everyone prepared everyone have
their calculators ready make sure that
they're approved calculators you want to
make sure you don't bring in real
high-tech software type you know
calculator that would have you banned
from the test or at least have your
calculator banned from the test make
sure you have an approved calculator
okay so Jessie says how come I use word
problem questions okay you're asking how
can you make the word problems easier
well that's a good question I mean if
you have a specific question maybe we
could do that let's see um my on is
could you please go over some geometry
problems and Miko's asking what is
expected value okay so all good
questions so as far as story problems go
you know what you want to do I mean they
give you a space you know usually on the
right side of the question there is you
want to try to draw a diagram you know
and then you want to try to write an
equation so usually I try to draw a
picture of some kind of some sort or
other and I try to then convert that
into an equation so maybe if you have a
more specific example you know we could
we could take a look at that but let's
see what were the other questions you're
talking about expected value so when you
talk about expected value what you're
doing is you know you're taking the
value of it of whatever it is and you're
multiplying by the probability that that
that that comes up so basically like say
for example the probability that you
roll a three let's say that's a 1/6
chance right and then so you take the
probability that you you know maybe you
roll like a four and say that's let's
just say that was like a one-third
chance I'm just doing a simple example
here but then what you would do is you'd
multiply these together multiply these
together and add and that would be your
expected value let's just pretend this
is some type of experiment so basically
that's your that's your formula it's
your outcome and then the probability
that that outcome occurs and then you
just sum up all those quantities so I
don't know if that answers your question
Miko but that seems to be something
that's showing up a little bit more on
the acct recently and some of that
release test but what other questions
what other questions do you have so
let's see you Omo oh my when I'm sorry
I'm pronounce your name I was asking
about can you go over some geometry
problems okay so I'm trying to think of
there's maybe something in specific you
wanted to talk about geometry wise I'll
give you an example here's an example so
when you talk about geometry problems of
course you want to know perimeter and
area right here is kind of like a
problem that shows up every once in a
while and sometimes what they'll do is
they'll ask you for the perimeter of
this shape okay but there's a little bit
of a technique to it and that's that you
know you can think of these segments as
being you know detached right and what
you can do is you can actually don't
move them over in such a way that you
can actually make this into a rectangle
and so you know the perimeter rectangle
is pretty easy to calculate you just
have to add up all the sides and you
know that's your perimeter so this
sometimes appears on the test of course
you also want to know your trigonometry
you know your sine cosine and tangent
you want to know your sohcahtoa
so we could do some problems like that
if you want but I mainly just wanted to
open this up to two questions and answer
so if you have more specific questions I
mean the more specific your question
that the better I might be able to you
know to answer that so what does
everyone think you want to ask me some
more questions about okay legendary
sideburns okay nice I like your name
there okay how do you find the area of
that
shape and then comb problems too please
okay says Kayden okay so comb problems
and we're talking about area okay well
as far as you know area goes one thing
you can do now I didn't really put any
numbers with this problem but what you
can do is you can subdivide it into
smaller shapes and then just find the
area that these individual pieces then
add them all together I didn't put any
numbers with this so that makes a little
bit more you know more challenging to
explain but if you can subdivide it
that's going to make a make it easier to
solve so but as far as comb problems so
let's take a look at me a comb problem
again the more specific you guys can you
know more information you guys can give
me the more I can kind of show you about
it but as far as a comb goes like here's
your cone right and there's two things
that you want to know you want to know
that you've got the height you've got
the slant height and you've got the
radius right and of course these are all
related by the Pythagorean theorem a
squared plus B squared equals C squared
but basically the two formulas you want
to know regarding cones are either
volume which is one-third the area of
the base times the height okay and then
now what you want to do is the base is a
circle so that's going to be PI R
squared times the height so again this
is the overall height to find the volume
but if you're finding the surface area
surface area is a little bit different
what you want to do is you want to take
the base plus the lateral area which is
one-half the perimeter of the base times
the slant height so in this case the
base is a circle so that's PI R squared
the perimeter of the base is a the
circumference that's 2 PI R and then you
have the slant height
well the 1/2 and the 2 they cancel each
other out so you could just write this
as PI R squared plus PI RL so that's
your surface area formula that's your
volume formula but let's see so some
other questions let's see let's see all
mobile my MN says such as inscribed
angles angle similarities and finding
sides that aren't congruent in triangles
ok so let me see if I understand your
question so as far as inscribed angles
go see okay so what he's asking or she's
asking is basically on if you have a
circle
and you've got two different things you
know going on here you have what's
called a central angle see because the
vertex is at the center and whatever
this angle is over here like say this is
at 85 degrees right this central angle
will also have a measure of 85 degrees
okay but inscribed angles they have
their vertex or their hinge like right
on the circle so see the difference like
this one's inside this one's on the
circle but when you have an inscribed
angle like this this angle measure is
half of the measure of the intercepted
arc so half of 85 is going to give us 42
point five so so that's a little bit
about inscribed angles let's see what
was your other question let's see it was
about finding sides that are congruent
and triangles well you know I'll tell
you one thing that comes up a lot on
them a CT the math section is you
definitely want to know your isosceles
triangles okay so when you look at
isosceles triangles we know that the
sides are congruent but if you know
those two sides are congruent then you
also know that the angles across from
those sides are congruent as well those
are called the base angles and those are
going to be congruent so yeah so that's
definitely another property that's
important to know so what do you think
what other questions what other
questions did you want to talk about
today we can talk about whatever you'd
like again you know I'm just promoting
my huge a CT math review video course if
you're interested in that there's a
three free previews on there you can
check that out to see if it's something
you're interested in there's a link in
the description of this video so I would
go and check that out if you want to see
more a CT videos go to my youtube
channel Mario's math tutoring and I've
got some playlists there that have
worked out previously release test so
you can kind of see how some of those
problems are worked out I also have some
different concepts that are covered on
the AC T and some of those videos so
head on over tomorrow's math tutoring
YouTube channel and okay legendary
sideburns is asking converting slope to
angle and vice versa okay so that's a
good question so converting the slope to
an angle and vice versa
well okay here let's take a look at that
so we know a couple things about slope
right
we know that the slope is the rise over
run right or if you have two coordinates
you can do y2 minus y1 over x2 minus x1
so that's if you know the two points but
let's just give you an example like
let's just say for example there's a
hill like this okay and let's just say
that it has a slope of I don't know
let's just say it's like 2/5 so okay so
yeah so basically somebody's asking
about the courses that I saw the a CT
math review course in the SAT math
review video of course yeah if you're
interested in those just click the link
in the description and that will take
you over to to those you can find out
more about that there but but yeah so
say for example they tell us that the
slope is two fist so we know that this
is two and then this is five so the rise
is the vertical and the run is the
horizontal but if you're trying to find
that angle of inclination right so the
angle of inclination or in this case
this is the angle of elevation so math
facts says how am I so good at math oh
yeah because I watched your videos
that's funny okay well I'm glad you're
enjoying the videos but yeah so then let
me ask you a question here so the person
who is asking about the slope what what
formula ties together the opposite side
get the one across from the angle and
the adjacent side so what trig function
is it sine is it cosine or is a tangent
what do you think so we've got the so
Toa hmm well it's going to be the
tangent because it's the opposite side
and the adjacent okay mfx right it's
tangent okay good
so what we want to do is we just want to
say the tangent of theta is equal to the
opposite okay Haley said tangent okay
you're right Haley good so it's opposite
over adjacent
now when you solve for the missing angle
what you do what you have to do is you
have to take the tangent inverse of both
sides of the equation so tangent inverse
of 2/5 and that will give you the angle
so so that's that's the key there so
basically want to do is you want to
position yourself at the angle itself at
that vertex and then find two sides and
then with this acronym the sohcahtoa
acronym it's all
going to be the second letter / the
third so opposite hypotenuse first sign
adjacent over hypotenuse for cosine and
opposite over adjacent for tangent so if
you're just joining us right now we're
just opening this up for some Q&A some
questions and answers to help students
prepare for the a CT that's coming up
this Saturday
and let's see Caden is asking about the
component form of a set of vectors okay
Kayden let me see if I understand and
let's see math effects is could you
briefly explain the difference between
arctan and what you used I know they're
the same but what should I use okay so
first math facts about arctan see this
tan -1 and arc tan they're exactly the
same so you can take the arctangent of
2/5 or the tangent inverse of 2/5 those
mean the same it's just two different
ways of writing it so that that's a good
question but the other the same but then
as far as the vectors are concerned
let's see if we can kind of talk about
that a little bit so basically if you're
just joining us right now we're just
confusion with inverse functions okay
okay can you talk about that a little
bit more in just just a moment let's
talk about vectors for a second so what
a vector is is you know has magnitude
and direction right so it's kind of like
say you're starting right here at this
point and you were going over to say
this point and that's the vector right
there but what's different about vectors
is you know it has a horizontal
component it has a vertical component so
to get from A to B we're going right
three and up one my diagram is not
perfect here so that means you would
write this in component form like this
three comma one so it's just like
horizontal see X direction and the
vertical Y direction so 3 comma 1 is the
vector that takes you from A to B now if
you knew the coordinates like in this
case let's see two three four five two
so B is 5 to a is at 2 1 what you do is
you take the terminal point minus the
initial point so 5 minus 2 gives you 3
right and 2 minus 1 gives you 1 so if
you take terminal minus initial that
will give you that you know the
resultant vector there so if you're just
joining us right now where this is kind
of a something that I do occasion I do
these live streams just to interact
every one a little bit more and so if
you have questions definitely ask the
questions and the more specific you can
be the more that I'll be able to answer
the question if you're liking the live
stream so far give me a thumbs up and if
you haven't subscribed to the channel
you know go ahead and subscribe and
check out more math tutoring videos
specifically about the AC T on my
youtube channel Mario's math tutoring
there's a bunch of AC T Channel videos
there on that channel and then also if
you're interested check the link in the
description I've got a huge AC t-- math
review video course for sale it has 65
concepts it's three and a half hours and
a lot of students have taken it already
and have told me about how they've been
able to boost their scores so there's
some free preview so I check that out to
see if it's something that you know that
you'd be interested in but definitely a
good way to kind of review key concepts
but let me look back into the chat here
real quick and now let's see some
questions so let's see so math facts was
asking about confusion with inverse
functions we can talk about that and
Miko's asking about let's see a chord 24
inches long is five inches from the
center of a circle what is the radius of
the circle to the nearest tenth of an
inch now that's a great question see I
like how specific that question is
because then we can really get into it
so here let's draw a picture here okay
so here we go so let me see if I can
read that again so a chord that's 24
inches long okay so I'll just draw it
like that
okay so chord it's five inches from the
center so there's your center right
there and I'm drawing a perpendicular
segment because when you draw a distance
from a point to a line it's always the
shortest distance the perpendicular
distance right and because this is 24
like this what happens when you draw
this perpendicular from the center to
the chord it bisects the chord Mikko
okay so now when you go to draw that
radius can anybody tell me what's the
length of that radius this is a good
question you know this is a geometry
question so what's interesting is
sometimes you know they don't show you
this triangle that's formed here so what
do you think how would you find the
radius now that they've given you that
now that I've kind of helped you a
little bit so you drew the distance
perpendicular distance it bisected the
chord all right so cut it in half
and then okay math facts is acting
asking about arctangent of 512 darshana
welcome any formulas that most people
don't know about but are tested on a CT
darshan that's a great question you know
if you check my last live stream they
did just a couple days ago we kind of
devoted the we devoted the whole live
stream basically to talking about key
facts in key formulas that you want to
know for the AC T so maybe check that
one out that probably beneficial for you
I'd see you nightly saying that take the
AC on the tenth and your videos out
really help me just wanted to say thank
you oh great I'm glad they helped you
thanks for letting me know
and let's see math X is saying five
squared plus twelve squared and Miko
saying is at thirteen and Ellie is
saying the five twelve thirteen triangle
to solve this yeah okay so everybody is
absolutely correct this is the
Pythagorean theorem or we can use what
they call Pythagorean triples a squared
plus B squared equals C squared or five
twelve thirteen Pythagorean triple so
yeah that's exactly right so the radius
is 13 so just a quick note if you want
to memorize these Pythagorean triples
they come up a lot when you take the AC
T 3 4 5 5 12 13 oh math X so this is a
really good stream okay good well I'm
glad you're benefiting so we're going to
talk about your your arctangent question
in just a second I might have to grab my
calculator I forgot to grab my
calculator it's behind me so let me grab
that a second but these come up a lot so
if you recognize that you've got a 3/4
then you know the hypotenuse is 5 or
yeah good question so I just says how do
you know which one is a B and C well the
C is going to be the largest one and the
a and the B are going to be the two
smaller ones the two legs so if you have
a 512 you know the hypotenuse is 13 of
course if you know the hypotenuse is 17
and one of the legs is 8 then you're
going to know that the other leg is 15
and again you can also use multiples of
these like if you multiply them all by 2
C 6 8 10 is also a right triangle a
Pythagorean triple or 10 24 26 so that's
that's the idea about the Pythagorean
triples you can also check I've got a
video on my Mario's math tutor and
YouTube channel just devoted all to
talking about how to work better with
the Pythagorean triples so you might
want to check that out too after after
you're done with this live stream but so
let's see so I want to
back in the chat they kind of go by a
little quick here so it says so let's
see so I think to ask to answer math
facts question about more about the you
know about the angles so let's look at
let's look at this example right here so
here's a tree right kind of a rough
rough diagram of a tree right and say
for example there's a bird on the tree
right here at the top okay and say the
bird is looking down at a little worm
over here okay it's kind of make this a
little funny right so basically what
this is what we want to figure out is
you know let's say you want to figure
out what's that angle of depression okay
from the bird to the worm okay but they
have to give us some more information so
for example like say for example this is
like let's see so this is okay dharshan
says I got a tricky question but
involves a diagram how should I post it
that's a good question dharshan I think
you're gonna have to try to describe it
to me just just because I'm I'm not an
expert yet at all this live streaming
but uh see if you can describe it
that'll probably the best thing but now
what I want you to notice in this
diagram here we're trying to find that
angle of depression so what you want to
do is you want to go ahead and realize
that this is a rectangle so the opposite
sides are congruent so this is a hundred
this is a hundred this is twenty five
this is twenty five but so math X so
tell me more so like what trig function
ties together this angle this side and
this side is it sine cosine or tangent
what does everyone think is it's sine
cosine or tangent that ties together
this angle this side and this side okay
yeah that's right you said tangent okay
effects so that's right so what you
would do is you'd say the tangent of the
angle so tangent of theta yep Austin
says tangent you're right Austin and the
remember the tangent is opposite over
adjacent Ellie's right tangent okay
everyone's right on so that's 25 over
100 but now here's the thing now math
facts is asking about arc tan and
tangent inverse and remember the exact
same thing so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to take the arc tan of the
left side of the equation okay that's
the same thing as a tangent inverse I'm
going to take the arc tan of the right
side of the equation right
and then these are inverses of one other
they cancel each other out so you get
that angle by itself now I have to go
ahead and reach for my calculator so
maybe see if you can check on your
calculator arctangent of 25 over 100 and
I'll see if I can grab mine right behind
me here see here okay so let's see so is
everyone with me so here's the ti-83
I've got a ti-84 in my car but this is
my my old calculator I'll just show you
on here so what you want to do is you
want to go over here to see the tangent
key right here you want to hit the
second key so second see the 10-1
tangent inverse I don't can you guys see
that tan inverse so we're going to do
the tangent inverse of 25 over 100 so 25
divided by 100 oops 100 and make sure
I'm in I'm in degrees right so that's it
so it's a 14 degree angle so did you
guys all get the same thing 14 degrees
I'll just put that down here okay so
let's see so what are some other
questions so if you're just joining the
live stream right now we're talking
about getting ready for the a CT and
okay math facts is saying my professor
said that using tan inverse can lead to
confusion with inverse functions
reflections and the line y equals x what
are your opinions on this I would say as
long as you know what you're doing you
know as long as you realize you're
taking arctangent of both sides you know
but I would do what's ever most
comfortable for you but they're
equivalent
okay dharshan saying in the figure below
BC is parallel to ad e is the midpoint
of a be F is the midpoint of C D G is a
midpoint of a e and H is the midpoint of
F to you what is the length of G H oh
that's a tough one darshana I wish I
could I wish I could see it because I
would be able to draw a picture and show
you but hmm let me let me think about
that one I don't know they you know I
think in the future I bet you YouTube
will probably have all kinds of cool
features where you can interact more you
know with the with the live chat but let
me see if I can answer that question
Austin is asking about matrix
multiplication so so yeah so as we're
doing this problem think of other
questions and the more specific you can
more specific that you can be then you
know the more I'll be able to draw a
diagram and kind of work through this
with you so maybe next time you know
we'll you know maybe we'll do something
where you can send in your like photos
or something like that head of time and
then I can maybe take a look at some of
the photos and then have them print it
out or something like that but okay so
but basically matrix multiplication
here's the idea right here so say this
is 2 3 1 & 0 right and say this is 1 & 4
right so now here's the thing actually
let me change this a little bit let's
make this 3 & 2 okay okay so let's see
if we got some good questions coming in
I'm gonna have to scroll back but here
we're talking about matrix
multiplication so the first thing is to
figure out the dimensions so the
dimensions are always the rows by the
columns right so in this case there's
two rows and there's two columns so
they're with me so far so two rows two
columns same thing with this one there's
two rows two columns now the key with
matrix multiplication is you want to
make sure that the inner dimensions are
the same and you end up with a matrix
that has the outer dimensions a 2x2 so
what I like to do is I like to draw that
final matrix okay two rows two columns
then if you're just solving for let's
just say like this one right here
okay this element you say well what
position is that in remember it always
goes rows first column second so you're
in the second row second column so that
tells us what to do you take the second
row times the second column so it's a 1
times 4 is 4 0 times 2 is 0
and you add those together and you get 4
so Austin is that making sense do you
want to ask me more about the matrix
multiplication so I'll show you another
one let's say you want to find this one
right here you take the let's see this
is in the second row first column so
you're taking the second row times the
first column now so this is 1 times 1
which is 1 0 times 3 which is 0 and then
you add those together which comes out
to 1 and you keep working your way
through so if I want to find this top
one that's in the first row first column
so you take the first row times the
first column so 2 times 1 is 2 3 times 3
is 9 if you add those together you get
11 and then the last one
first row second column 2 times 4 is 8 3
times 2 is 6 and 14 ok so let me let me
see if I can scroll back so there were
some questions that came through so
let's see okay Austin says I see now
okay good
so in circle o seek an ADB and AEC are
drawn from external point a such that
point DBE and C are in circle oh okay
let me see if I can draw this picture so
I don't know if this is something
necessary they're going to have on the
ECT but we can try to attempt it here so
see if I'm on the right track with this
one so on circle o seek an ADB okay and
DB E and C are on the circle so let me
see so this is a let's see what here it
is seek an ADB so this is a DB and let's
see D okay and AEC like this okay and it
says if ad is 8 okay and what does it
say
AE is 6 and EC is 12 more than BD so
that means that this is X this is 12
more X plus 12 what's the length of BD
okay so I'll just show you the formula
really quick on this one but this is
really not going to be something on the
ECT you know that they're going to test
you on it I mean they do tell C on
circles and that kind of thing but
here's the formula right here so what
you do is you take the total length of
that secant okay which is going to be X
plus eight and then you multiply times
the external part ok Mason's asking a
question yet so we'll get to that one
just a second and then that's equal to
this whole secant length ok this whole
secant length which is what X plus 18
times its external part which is 6 and
then all I have to do is solve that so
it's the whole secant times the external
part equals the whole secant times the
external part so does that answer your
question I wish I could say your name
better I apologize ohm my when I gate oh
yeah so the help that answers that
better so let's say Mason's asking hmm
when a number X is subtract
did from 36 the difference is divided
and the difference is divided by X the
result is 2 what is the value of X so
let me see if I can write that down so
it says when a number X is subtracted so
number X is subtracted from 36 and the
difference is divided well I think I'm
going to get another sheet of paper here
I got botched that one so it says when a
number X is subtracted from 36 right
okay and the difference is divided by X
the result is 2 what is the value of x
ok now this is you know this is a
typical acct question and what they're
testing you on here is a couple
different things like you can think of
this as a proportion it's a ratio equal
to ratio and just solve this all you
have to do is do your cross multiplying
so you're multiply on the diagonal so
it'd be 2 times X is 2x and 36 minus X
times 1 is 36 minus X and if you add X
to the other side you get 3x equals 36
and if you divide by 3x equals 12 and
you got it so Mason does that answer
your question
so just cross multiplying basically okay
very helpful okay great so if you're
just joining the live stream right now
what we're doing is basically just
opening up for questions and answers so
if there's some questions that you have
like the more specific it can be the
more we can you know more I can help you
with that and the more we can kind of
interact with one another and get your
questions answered I know everyone's
prepared for the acct Saturday but just
to just to let you know I have a huge a
CT math review video course for sale if
you want to get some more help you know
above and beyond what we're doing here
today
and you can see the link is in the
description of the you know of this
video so if you go there you can see and
find out more there's three free
previews so you can check that out and
you'll get some benefit from those and
then you can decide if it's something
that's right for you so I would check
that out and then also go to my channel
Mario's math tutoring and I've got a
bunch of different playlists you know
where I've solved out some a CT problems
from previously released tests that's
been really helpful to a lot of students
and I've got some different concepts
that are covered but I would just go
over there and visit that if you haven't
subscribed already
and subscribe to the channel if you're
liking this video in this livestream you
know give me a thumbs up and appreciate
that I'll make sure to do more of these
and so there's a lot of stuff coming in
through the chat here let me see let me
scroll back here so we've got a case so
we were able to answer
Mason's question okay our RSS can we do
questions that are towards the end of
the math a CT questions yeah are
definitely we certainly can those tend
to be a little bit more challenging so
see if you can maybe pick one that's you
know one that you can maybe describe to
me and we can work it out I also have
that I have the two a CT books you know
with me here I can maybe see if I can
get to them but if you can describe what
you're talking about maybe I can answer
that
Aisha says how do you know when to use
our tangent or regular tangent oh that's
a great question I you should well the
difference is when you know the angle or
when you don't know the angle so when
you don't know the angle and you're
solving for the missing angle that's
when you use the arctangent okay and
when you know the angle then use the
regular tangent I'll show you an example
okay and let's see our RSS okay thank
you okay and Austin has a question about
let's see solving for i okay we can do
that problem and Ally's got a question
okay so good good question systems of
equations okay we're going to get to all
these questions so let's let's keep
going here so basically to quickly
answer about that tangent arctangent
question so you can clear that up once
and for all
so CV you guys can figure this out if
this is 25 and this is X and this is age
should we use tangent or arctangent what
do you think tangent or arctangent so
you're standing over here at the angle
this is the opposite side this is the
adjacent side what do you think should
we use tangent or arctangent Austin says
tangent okay you're right Austin because
we have the angle so we're gonna use
regular tangent Aisha says tangent okay
okay yup cadence says tangent yeah
exactly right so what you would do is
you would just save tangent of the angle
equals opposite side over the adjacent
side remember the Toa
it's absolutely jacent second over third
then you just multiply both sides by
eight and you got it
now compare and contrast that with with
this question right so say for example
this is three and this is seven and this
is theta do we use tangent or arctangent
to solve for this missing angle here
what do you
think tangent or arctangent or you could
call it tangent inverse of yuan or
tangent -1 what do you think arctangent
Austin saying you should sing our
tangent Elly's saying arctangent Haley's
saying arc because you don't know the
angle Miko saying arc yeah you're
absolutely right so whenever you want to
solve for the missing angle that's when
you use the arc tan or I like to use tan
minus 1 that's the tangent inverse of
3/7 equals theta again it's the opposite
over adjacent and the reason I use tan
minus 1 as you can see here on my old
calculator here see right above the
tangent to tangent inverse use that
second key that's going to solve for
that missing angle so if you're just
joining us right now we're opening this
up for questions to help students
prepare on the prayer for the math
section of the acct coming up on
Saturday so so if you have questions in
a more detailed you can make it the more
will be able to draw it out here in
front of us and interact with the you
know interact with you so yeah so I hope
this is helping if you're just getting
here now again I just keep mentioning my
hue JCT math review video course check
that out in the description there's some
three some previews there you can see if
it's right for you but it goes through
65 concepts and Neville is asking when
is the SAT livestream today we're just
focusing on the a CT 4 because it's
coming up on Saturday but let's see we
had some other questions so let's go
back to those questions let's see where
are those let's go back here ok so let's
see all right so Austin was saying well
let's see I think I answered one AUSA's
will do yours next Austin let's look at
Ellie's next and then we'll get to
Austin's so you're wondering about
systems of equations Ellie is that what
you're wondering about you've got X plus
y equals 32 and X minus y equals 12 okay
so is everyone familiar with systems of
equations so what do you think like how
would we solve this system we're trying
to find out like what x and y are what
would you do first any ideas anybody
want to jump in on the on the chat there
how would you solve the system of
equations well there's three different
methods right there's a graphing there's
a
substitution there's elimination okay
let's see okay Ally wassing I think
substitution you're thinking
substitution that will sing substitution
Austin says you can eliminate X see
Dowell saying add X&Y Mikko saying
substitution ok Mason sub ok ok great so
I'm has really on interacting that's
great so I want to show you something
really quick so you want to solve this
right but you see if you just add
straight down you see how Y and negative
Y are going to cancel each other out
take as ones positive ones negative so
if you just add straight down this is
going to give you 2x equals 44 and then
if you just divide by 2 you get x equals
22 then if you put it back in to either
one of these equations you can solve for
y so if I just put into that top
equation we get 22 plus y equals 32 and
if you subtract 22 from both sides you
get 10 so our final answer is 22 10 now
you know on the ECT it's multiple choice
right so if this is one of the choices
what you could do is you could put 22
and 10 make sure that adds up to 32 and
22-10 make sure that you know subtracts
to give you 12 so as long at me as it
makes both equations true you know
you've got the right answer you know and
so a lot of students that define that
you know quicker just a back substitute
and see which one works but when they're
lined up like this le you're better off
probably just adding straight down as
long as either the Y's are going to
cancel out or the X's are going to
cancel out and if you want to find out
more about this you know go to my
Mario's math tutor and YouTube channel
and look up systems of equations
elimination method or systems of
equations substitution or just look up
systems of equations you'll see some my
videos I did on that ok so let's see
other questions try to be I'm really
specific like that one was so we can you
know kind of answer that better so go
ahead and put the questions in the chat
we'll try to get to them here and if
you're just joining us and you haven't
subscribed yet subscribe to the channel
if you're liking this video you know
give it a thumbs up so I know to do more
of these in the future
let's see Kate and I want to come back
to your question you're asking what are
the values of theta between 0 and 2pi
where the tangent of theta equals
negative 1 that's a good question you
know I don't think this is really
something you need to know for the AC T
but you know
I just I want to make sure that
everybody's getting something out of
this so okay so basically between zero
and 2pi that's once around the unit
circle right and you know where does
tangent data equal negative one well
that's going to be right over here at 3
PI over 4 or you could say this is 135
degrees so that's knowing your unit
circle there's not really a whole lot of
that on that ect I wouldn't worry about
that too much but they asked answer your
question I hope so okay let's see what
other questions are there I want to you
guys are asking some really good
questions let's see what other ones
where they let me scroll through the
chat here Mason's asking let's see when
a particular number is added to its own
reciprocal the resulting sum is negative
2 the number is which of the following
okay yeah that's a good question Mason
so let's see so a lot of its just you
know and this is a good you know this is
a good thing to understand is how do you
translate from a sentence into you know
an equation right so when a particular
number we'll just call that particular
number X right and is added to its own
reciprocal the resulting sum is negative
2 so sum means add okay the number is
which of the following well here's the
thing if you if you on the AC T it's
multiple choice so you could just plug
in those values and see which one is
going to give you negative 2 right so
that's probably the easiest way but if
you want to see me solve this what I can
do is clear the denominators right so if
we want to clear the denominators let's
multiply everything by X if you're just
joining us we're just doing QA for the
AC T math section that's coming up
Saturday and if you have questions put
them in the chat and I'll try to try to
get to them and again as I'm going
through this I'm also kind of letting
people know about that huge a CT math
review video course that I have for sale
there's a link in the description to
this video so check that out there's
some free previews you can see if it's
something that's right for you and also
on my Mario's mastering YouTube channel
I've got a lot of different videos
talking about the a CT so you can check
those out as well so you can see how I'm
solving this I Mason C I'm basically
trying to get everything on one side now
what I'm doing is I'm factoring and I'm
taking the square root of both sides so
you can see this is
X plus one equals zero and if I subtract
one I'm getting x equals negative one so
the answer is going to be negative one
in this particular problem so I hope
that answer your question but yeah so
let's take a look so I had some other
questions coming in Nico's asking let's
see what's the distance in the standard
coordinate plane between one zero and
zero five okay let's talk about that one
so distance formula is definitely
something important to know for the AC T
and so we said one zero and zero five so
that what you said okay let me take a
look real quick one zero and zero five
so there's a couple different ways to do
this Mikko one way is you can plot the
points okay okay and notice what I'm
doing right here is I'm drawing this
into a right triangle so you could just
say well this is one and this is five
and we can do our Pythagorean theorem a
squared plus B squared equals C squared
which means this is going to be square
root of 26 but I think maybe what you
might be asking about is you know what's
that distance formula x2 minus x1
squared plus y2 minus y1 squared you add
them together take the square root so if
we do that let's see 0 minus 1 is
negative 1 squared 5 minus 0 is 5
squared and so then we get 25 plus 1
which is a square root of 26 so did that
answer a question Miko did did you oh
did you follow that with the distance
formula or you can do the Pythagorean
theorem okay let's see dharshan okay I
apologize dharshan you I think sometimes
it's I think you wanted to asking some
tough questions which is which is good
but I want to make sure I can write them
down let's see Lin has a 367 in quarters
dimes nickels and pennies she arranges
these coins and rows and notices that
there are five more dimes than quarters
and there's one more nickel than
quarters and 25 more pennies and
quarters how many pennies does Lin have
okay so basically you know this is what
you're asking is a systems of equations
so let me see if I can set up the
equation so so Linda is 367 in quarters
dimes and nickels so how much is a
quarter worth well quarters worth 25
cents times the number of quarters right
and then let's see you've got a nickel
and dimed go to sea quarters dimes
nickels and pennies so you've got dimes
which are ten cents right and you've got
let's see nickels which are five cents
right and what else pennies which of
course are one cent and that adds up to
3.67 cents now here's the thing dharshan
if you have four variables how many
equations do you need you need four
equations right so notice is there are
five more dimes than quarters so the
number of dimes equals the quarters plus
five right let's see and then let's see
there's one more nickel than quarters so
the number of quarters I'm sorry the
number of nickels is the number of
quarters plus one see one more nickel
than quarters and twenty five more
pennies in quarters so the number of
pennies is the number of 25 more pennies
it's the number of quarters plus 25 okay
so dharshan so are you with me so far on
this I hope this is helping but check
this out so if you take D okay and this
is the answer I think Elly's question
from earlier about substitution see if
you take D see how it equals Q plus five
so we can put that in place of D there
right and you see n how it is Q plus one
so that means that you can put that in
place of n right there and you see the
number of pennies is equal to Q plus 25
oh I forgot my P over here for pennies
right you put that in there and then
what happens is you've got all this are
going to be in terms of Q for quarters
and you're gonna be able to solve for
the number of quarters then once you
know the number of quarters you can put
it back in here and find the number of
dimes nickels and pennies but this is a
good technique is to use that first
letter and so that's going to make it a
lot easier okay Darshan's happy about
that I made it easier okay just remember
however many variables you have that's
how many equations you have all right so
well let me look at the chat again so
you guys are you guys are enjoying this
okay I can tell and you're really asking
some good questions okay so let's see
okay so let's see Kayden's asking you
know what's the log let's see base 5 of
5 and 13 halves okay let me see about
that one Kaden let me
see if I can write that one down so if
you have questions and you're just
joining us right now you know put them
in the chat try to be as descriptive as
you can so I can you know write this
down so we can all you know benefit from
it and let me see if I can write down
Kayden's question here really quick do I
have that right Kaden log base 5 of 5
and 13 halves is that is that right
let's see hmm you know what I'm not sure
that I I'm not sure that I quite
understand this but you know what let me
see if I can tell you something that
might be that might help you oh five
thirteen five thirteen halves is raised
500 I see what you're saying Oh log base
five five to the 13 halves power that's
what you're saying Kaden right yeah so
that's a good question so see how this
is log base five and this is an
exponential function and it's also base
five see logs and exponential functions
they're inverses of each other so what
happens is they cancel one another out
and you just get 13 halves see on the
ECG usually they just ask you know they
ask questions like and here's the key
thing is do you know how to switch from
one form to another like see say for
example you have log base 3 of 9 equals
X right and you say well I want to
figure out what X is right so you say
well how do I switch from the Log form
to the exponential form well because
logs and exponential functions are
inverses if we exponentiate both sides
so we raise both sides using base 3
because those are inverses of one
another they cancel each other out now
you just have to say 3 to what power is
9 we can see 3 to the second power is 9
so the answer is going to be 2 so that's
the main thing is knowing how to switch
between the two forms if you have more
questions about that you can find out
another video on my youtube channel
Mario's math tutoring it's just look up
logs I've got all kinds of videos about
logs how to evaluate logs so that would
be a good resource for you but let's
look in the chat here I know there's
some other questions if you're just
joining us right now we're just doing a
little Q&A to get ready for the a CT
math section you know on Saturday and
I'm also letting everyone know that I've
got
that huge a CT math review video course
for sale check that out there's a link
in the description see if it's something
that you're interested in it's got three
and a half hours of video and there's
sixty-five casts that are cover to help
you boost your score on the ECT so we
focus on you know typical problems that
you might see formulas you want to know
how to work with different questions a
lot of students have taken it so that's
a helping booster score so check out the
link in the description and if you're
just joining us now you know subscribe
to the channel and like this video if
you're finding it helpful but I'm going
back in the chat it looks like oh my
when I get o is asking let's see a point
is on side M such that M Q 2 Q n is 2 to
3 if M has coordinate 3 5 and n has
coordinate of Q o n has coordinate of
something Q R what are they if I
understand the question so basically hmm
you've got MN M s coordinate 3/5 let's
try to draw a picture here so we've got
let's see 3 5 1 2 3 1 2 3 4 5 3 5 and
what else does it say there it says M Q
is 2 Q n is in the ratio 2 to 3 so this
is point M and I think I need a little
bit more information on this one so and
has coordinate of is n coordinate of o
as n is then at the origin I'm not sure
what you mean here or NS coordinate of
oh like the origin and you're trying to
figure out you know where is a and has
coordinate 8 5 the coordinate of Q is
hmm let's see here I don't think this
question is going to be on the a CT so I
wouldn't worry about this one too much
the things you want to worry about for
the a CT are more like a midpoint
formula distance formula things like
things like that that's a good question
but it's a little bit hard for me to
maybe get exactly where you're going
with that but let's see what other
questions does everyone have okay Miko
is asking about the ratio of the radii
of two circles is forward
9 what is the ratio of the circumference
--is that's a good question Miko so this
is definitely something that's important
like ratios so so here's a little circle
here's a larger circle the ratio of the
radii are 4 to 9 well if you wanted to
you don't have to do this but you could
do the circumference of both of these ok
circles and compare them but what you're
going to notice is the ratio of the
radii is going to be the same as a ratio
of the circumference --is so the ratio
would still be 4 to 9 but let me ask you
guys a tougher question what's the ratio
of the areas of the circles what do you
think that would be so the ratio the
circumference is the same as the ratio
of the radii for deny and that's the
scale factor but what's the ratio of the
areas does anybody know the answer to
that one what do you guys think let me
get a drink of water here hmm
so if you're just joining us right now
we're just doing some practice for the
acct math section and i'm promoting
@hyou JCT math review video course and I
have for sale to help students boost
your score on the math section of the
acct the links in the description to
this to this video so check that out
it's got three and a half hours of video
65 different concepts
there's teaching there's example
problems it's a really good resource I
try to distill down some of the most
important concepts see da was saying PI
R squared yeah that's true yeah the area
of a circle is PI R squared but what's
the ratio of the areas what's the ratio
of this areas to this area so what do
you think what's the ratio of the areas
if you have questions and you're just
joining us now go ahead and put them in
the chat the more descriptive you can be
the more I'll be able to kind of work
through them and help you guys out and
again if you go to my youtube channel
Jack sang-hyeok a hijack dharshan saying
16 to 81 miko saying 1681 that's exactly
right it's all you have to do is take
the scale factor and square it Haley
sings 16 over 81 okay good yeah you guys
are all right very good but let me ask
you another question just to take this
up a notch see that this is actually
like a sphere
okay you know like a ball like a sphere
right what's the ratio of the volume ya
dharshan saying cubit yeah you're
exactly right you take that scale factor
and you would cubic so now you're
talking about three dimensions so it's
going to be 64 over 729 right yeah
exactly right so you just have to ask
yourself is it one dimensional like
length or circumference is a two
dimensional like area or is it three
dimensional like volume so it's volume
you're going to want to cube the scale
factor okay so let's see so what other
questions what other questions do you
guys have things you want to talk about
in this chat here and see Mason's asking
another question about the sum of the
integers P and Q is 495 so P plus Q
equals 495 right okay what else may sit
on that one it says that P is divided by
10 the result is equal to Q what is the
value of P so you know it sounds like
Mason you have a lot of questions about
these systems of equations or actually I
don't know if it's just you but a lot of
students have been asking today just
about systems of equations I would
definitely go over to my Mario's math
tutor and YouTube channel look up
systems of equations and there's a
substitution elimination graphing method
definitely something helpful to you know
to help you to solve these but you know
what I would do on this one Mason is
that multiply both sides by 10 that way
we solve for P so P equals 10 times Q
Jack's saying if I am from England when
should I take the AC T and also what
advice you have for revision up for the
AC t you I think you mean like review
for the AC T yeah Jack I would I'm
recommending everyone check out my huge
a CT math review video course there's a
link in the description to this video
and if you check that out there's some
free previews you can see if it's right
for you but that's what I would do is go
to the description check out that link
and I've got a nice video course that's
really helpful but now see check this
out Mason if P equals 10 Q we can put
that in place of P right now we just
have one equation with Q's you can solve
for Q once you know Q you can put it
back in and solve for P so I hope that
answer your question let's see what
we've got a lot of people tuning in from
all
that's great let's see I didn't quite
catch s cans question miss Brown is a
stockbroker at a major firm she makes a
1.2 percent commission based on the
total assets she has under management by
what percentage will the amount of money
she makes grow if the assets she manages
go from 10 million to 12 million okay so
what saying by what percentage will the
amount of money she makes grow if the
asset she manage to go from 10 10
million to 12 million she makes one
point represented based on the total
assets she has under management by what
percentage will the amount of money she
make makes grow if the assets she
manages go from 10 million to 12 million
hmm trying to see if I understand that
question as makes 1.2 percent commission
based on the total assets she has under
management by what percentage will the
amount of money she makes grow a little
confused maybe you can tell me a little
bit more about it so it goes from 10
million to 12 million so she basically
it grew by 2 million
but are you I think if I think if I
understand what you're asking like one
question that comes up on the acct is
we're trying to focus on a CT is this
percent of change formula and if you
want to know more about some of the
different formulas the last live stream
that I did like two days ago we talked
we kind of devoted it to talking about
formulas and so you might want to check
that one out I was just a couple days
ago but percent of change is what it's
the new amount minus the old amount
divided by the old amount sometimes they
say new minus original over original but
I just write old because it's a little
bit easier to write but that gives you
your percent of change
you just have to convert it to a
percentage so that's the idea okay let's
see what other questions so let's see RR
is saying let's see cupcake nation I
skipped cupcake nation so if X is a real
number such that X cubed is equal to 64
then x squared plus the square root of x
equals blank okay for cube see plug 4
for X and then that is your answer to
this help oh yeah okay great oh so our R
is jumping into answering cupcake
nation's questions oh-ho good all right
good I'm glad you guys are helping each
other in this chat this is this is this
is good we've got got the whole
community
working together I like that so Jack's
asking do you have any advice for
studying for the ECT science and English
papers aw Jack I just focus on the math
part so I'm not I'm not sure what to
tell you about the acct science in
English I just focus on the math Mason
says you mind review my question answer
gimme wasn't what I was looking for
sorry okay let's see what other
questions up you know you guys have and
that we're right about the hour mark
right now as you try to keep it -
depends how much activity we have just
how much interest we have and that sort
of thing we can keep going for for
longer if you want but again if you
haven't subscribed yet subscribe to the
channel if you like this video give it a
thumbs up so I know to do more of these
in the future
and if you have questions write me a
detailed question in the chat you know
try to if it's a shorter question it's
easier for me to do and if it's more
details easier for me to write out here
but there's a lot of ECT videos on my
youtube channel so I would check those
out so if you're trying to look for you
know previously released tests that I
solved you know I solve the questions
that you know for those tests a lot of
those on there and I also have a lot of
formulas a lot of videos about you know
how to approach the tests and so forth
and then kind of the big thing that I'm
promoting today is that huge a CT math
review video course it has 65 concepts
it's over three and a half hours of
video and that's for sale through the
link in the description in in the in
this video so if you go to the
description you'll see the link there a
lot of students have benefited from that
okay let's see dow is asking this
question saying what is 537 to the one
hundred and second power well okay
there's a little bit of a trick to this
question and I'm trying to think how to
do it exactly right now but if you take
what you have to do is you have to
figure out there's a pattern okay now
you have to figure out how many digits
there's a repeating pattern here but
once you find that repeating pattern
okay Ali says thank you so much for this
and it's helped a lot look good luck on
the test all okay great
okay good so thanks for joining us
Abby's a Mason plug-in your answer for Q
into the original equation to find P
okay good so yeah Abby's helping you out
there Mason so check that out but yeah
does anybody have some input on this one
I know this is a this is actually a
question that comes up occasionally but
there's a pattern here I'm just it's
escaping me at the moment but there's so
many digits that repeat and you have to
figure out like you know what that
repetition is and then kind of go from
there like I'll give you a similar
example maybe this will help you down
like say if you had like so you had a
repeating decimal like this four one
three eight four one three eight four
one three eight dot dot dot right so
what do you think the 200 well let's say
the 201 digit is right so the one way
over here 201 well because it's
repeating every four digits right four
digits you would take 201 you would
divide by four so that goes into how
many times five okay so this is a 50
times remainder one so this is going for
one three eight four one three eight
four one three eight fifty times and
then on that first digit then you'd be
back to four if it was remainder to be
at one three and then if it was no
remainder you'd be right at eight so
that's the idea is it's a you know it's
a repetition you have to see how many
times it repeats and then look at the
remainder and that's going to take you
to the to the digit that you want so
okay so all right so other questions
that you guys want to ask about anything
else you want to talk about on this
review here so for the acct and
everyone's getting up ready for Saturday
so what do you think other questions you
want to talk about what do you think so
if you haven't yet you know check out
some of the more videos I did on my
channel the ECT videos that I did you
can check those out for more help
Darshan's helping out Mason good Kaden
is asking about cylinders Haley is
asking for any imaginary number I which
of the following is a possible value of
I to the N if n is an inch or less than
five okay Haley let's answer your
question and we're going to talk about
cylinders two now you know a cylinder is
like this right and the main thing is to
know the volume of the cylinder which is
the area of the base times the height so
it's going to be area the base such as a
circle which is PI R squared H so that's
the main thing to know is how to work
with that
but as far as I let's look at imaginary
numbers see the main thing to remember
is this is that I equals a square root
of negative 1 I squared is equal to
negative 1 I cubed is equal to negative
I and I to the fourth is equal to 1 and
then it repeats this would be I to the
fifth 6 7 8 and it just keeps going
around every 4 like that so if you had I
to the 23rd for example this is this is
an interesting problem I to the 23rd as
I squared to the 11th with one left over
because power to a power you multiply
rights that's 22 and but we know I
squared is negative 1 right and what's
the negative 1 to an odd power it's
negative 1 and then times I you get
negative I so that's a one way to look
at is to think about how many times it's
2 going to 23 and then what's left over
and then you can simplify it like I just
did here so I hope that answer your
question about how to work with I to two
different powers
ok so Hayley out that helped so I mean
you can either memorize these for CS is
asking a question if Jeremy took 180
minutes to travel 240 miles what was the
speed in miles per hour
well how many how many minutes is how
many hours is 180 minutes it's 3 hours
and so if you think about 240 miles per
3 hours
miles per hour whenever you see the word
per that means divided by so 240 divided
by 3 is actually going to be 3 miles per
hour right so per means divided by the
key though on that one essence just to
get the unit's correct you know so yeah
you can also use this formula yo
distance equals rate times time and then
just solve for solve for the rate by
dividing by the time but the key was to
get your units correct you know in terms
of hours and miles so yeah a distance
equals rate times time is a good one all
right good
yeah Oh Darsh and jumped in on that one
okay good all right great yeah you guys
are helping each other this is good
maybe I can get to the point where I can
just step aside and you guys can take
over the live chat that's that's the
goal right so you guys help each other
and everyone get their questions
answered right okay so any other
questions you know just I'm glad you
guys are all working together this is
great I've done some live streams where
it gets kind of crazy and people just
kind of get kind of silly and all that
kind of stuff and it's better when
everyone works together like you guys
are right now so let's see Hayden's
jumping in okay welcome to the chat
Hayden let's see let's see what your
question is and math facts as one and
let's see okay let me see if I
understand your question okay two
questions let me see so it says Express
1 over P 2p minus 1
in partial fractions oh okay that's a
great question
math facts I would go over to my channel
and I've got a whole bunch of videos on
partial fraction decomposition so I
would go ahead and take a look at that
that's not going to be tested on the ECT
but if you're interested I've got videos
on my Morrow's math tutor and youtube
channel and i show you how to break
those down those partial fractions
Hayden's asking let's see 10 to the 2x
minus 1 divided by X let's see equals 1
what is X equal hmmm Hayden can you okay
okay I see what you're saying so do I
have this right by the way Hayden is
this do I have this right 10 to the 2x
minus 1 divided by x equals 1 x equals
blank okay Caitlin is asking about
percent questions I really strongly
struggle with those okay okay we're
going to talk about percent questions oh
the exponent is all divided by X okay
thanks for clearing up okay okay and FX
is jumping in and saying zero yeah
that's right you guys are doing so good
okay see the thing is is 10 to what
power equals 1 the zero power so only
way this will equal one is if 2x minus 1
over X is equal to zero but what's going
to make this equal to zero well the only
way this would be zero is if the
numerator is 0 and the denominator all
right so that means that if
X is 1/2 2 times 1/2 is 1 minus 1 equals
0
so that's it's 1/2 so that was kind of a
trick question but yeah this is knowing
your rules of exponents anything to the
0 power is 1 so that was a little little
tricky good question though let's see
what else is coming in ok so Caitlin
Caitlin whoever's asking us
let's see I took a math prep talk about
percentage problems ok so here is a
percentage problem just a simple one but
see if you can kind of get this one so
say for example you went to a store and
let's see say for example you there was
a 6% sales tax and the total that you
paid was $48 so what was the original
price of the item before the sales tax
can you guys and gals solve that problem
so if you went to a store you bought
something there's a 6% sales tax that
totals $48 how do you find out what it
was before the taxes charged that's a
percentage problem let's see what do you
think on that one Kaelyn is that one
kind of like the problem that you're
experiencing when you're doing these
problems earlier let's see so see if you
guys can answer this one 6 percent and
the new total is 48 what was the
original price and let's see Darshan's
asking a question X to the to a equals 3
then X to the 6 a equals how much case
dharshan okay see if you guys can answer
each other's questions that's that's the
best
let's see Abby saying hmm negative sign
2 squared theta and I'm not sure about
your question maybe you can tell us a
bit more about that one let's see our
are saying forty five dollars and twelve
cents question mark is he right math
facts is saying 48 develop divided by
0.9 for Caitlin saying no sir it's more
challenging okay we'll do a more
challenging one after that okay you guys
can just call me Mario by the way okay
cupcake nation so it's 45 dollars and 12
cents
Mikko says 66 and here this is I got 45
dollars okay because 66 okay here's the
thing so a little bit of confusion here
but this is what you want to do is see
the original price let's call that X
when you had charged a 6% sales tax then
you have to pay the original price which
is a hundred percent plus an additional
whoops plus an additional six percent
right and that equals the new price
which is 48 right but the thing is this
is a hundred and six percent of the
original price equals a new price right
but when you when you do this you want
to convert that into a decimal one point
zero six times x equals 48 so when you
when you think about it it's one which
is the original price plus the
additional amount for the tax so you're
actually paying 106 percent and that's
how you're getting 48 so you really want
to divide that both sides by 1.06 okay
and so 48 divided by 1.06 let's do that
on the calculator here forty-five
dollars and twenty-nine cents
oh so everybody was thinking it was
super easy but it wasn't as easy as as
we thought
right so percentages are definitely
something important for the AC t you
want to really you really want to get
those down but think about a hundred
percent plus six percent in this
particular problem okay we've been case
also you add it instead of subtracting
it math X is 50 88 oh okay
s is asking about a circle equation and
it says what is the radius can anybody
answer s this question so he's got a
question about a circle you definitely
wanna know the formula for the equation
of a circle on the AC T definitely an
important question see if anyone can
answer ask this question and let's see
our R says it's 10 if you square root
the 100 then you get 10 you use a circle
equation yeah that's it that's that's
right that's exactly right so ya circle
equation very important for the AC T so
I like what you guys are helping each
other Katelyn it says this 10 okay but
Caitlin was asking about more difficult
percentage questions
Haley's saying 10 yeah good you guys are
doing great so let me ask you guys a
question have you guys checked out that
huge a CT math review video course that
Darcy's asking thought of teaching SAT
to math 1 or math to you know I did
actually I thought about maybe doing
some videos on that but I have
got around to it quite yet but uh-oh the
other thing I want to let you guys know
about too is if you're interested in
private tutoring online tutoring for the
AC T or just math in general you can
contact me about that we can FaceTime or
we can do some online tutoring some
available for that if you're just
joining the live stream now we're
talking about some Q&A for getting ready
for the AC T on Saturday and I'm letting
everybody know about my huge AC t-- math
review video course and that's available
for sale through the link in my in the
description so check out the huge a CT
math review video of course I did it's
got 65 concepts three and a half hours
of video and so check that out see if
that's something that that you're
interested in there's three free preview
so you can see if it's something that
you know that you'll benefit from a lot
of students have taken it and reported
back to me that it's really helped them
boost their scores so I think you'll get
benefit out of it as well so definitely
check that out you've still got a couple
couple days to do some studying with
that and if you want to reach out to me
you can go to my Mario's math room your
YouTube channel to watch more videos
where I just cranked through a bunch of
problems you know on previously released
tests so you can kind of you can kind of
work that out so yeah you guys are
helping each other in the chat really
well so that's that's great
yeah as you guys are doing really good
oh I didn't see the floor there on the
SS question yes so I didn't see the four
you have to divide by four first yeah
there you go yeah so yep good question
so yeah you guys are helping each other
out sometimes it's tough to read the
chat once it's flying by you're on my
screen here but yeah so other questions
you want to talk about you guys are
doing really good helping each other and
what do you think anything else you want
me to maybe work on right here that we
can talk about together questions you
have what do you think other things you
want to talk about s-said yeah when I
took the practice test I miss the head
yeah yeah that's good so sometimes when
you see it you know right in front of
you you just want to you know what I do
when I do these problems I read through
the question really quick I glanced at
the answers to kind of see what form the
answers are in then I go back and I try
to pick it out of course I always try to
draw you know a diagram pass
and writing equation sometimes you can
back substitute yeah so Mason sings wish
you could be more comfortable to mass
section well you know what practice
makes perfect you know I would do a lot
of the practice tests if you guys
oh yeah Katelyn reminding me about
complicated percent problems okay yeah
here's here's a percent problem Katelyn
so here's the question right okay so
okay a be sorry I missed your question
earlier it says which of the following
is equivalent to sine theta cosecant
negative theta
wherever sine theta cosecant theta is
defined you know usually these problems
they don't they don't have too much of
these on the a CT a B it's the most
challenging it really gets is like you
know knowing that tangent is equal to
sine over cosine that kind of that kind
of thing there's not like a whole lot of
like identities and like simplifying
expressions like that yes I wouldn't
worry about that one too much for the
ECT but as far as difficult percent
questions like see say for example you
ran let's say you biked okay let's say
you biked eight miles right and then you
let's say you let's say you improve your
how many miles you can bike by ten
percent and then you improve the
following day after that by an
additional twenty percent so I'm just
going to make a little notes but I'm
just going to say this I'm just going to
say this out loud so basically say you
wrote eight miles on your bike then the
day after that you wrote an additional
you know ten percent and the day after
that you wrote an additional 20 percent
by what percentage did you increase your
total distance byte so that's a little
bit more challenging percentage problem
halia see if you can figure that out so
you're increased here and everyone
that's listening to see if you can do
this so it says Oh Darsh and says check
out his review course I took the one on
you to me and it was great the one he
has now is even better
whoo dharshan thanks for thanks for
letting everybody know about that yeah
the udemy one was just kind of like me
getting started and then I started
getting a bit better making these video
courses I moved it over to a different
platform and now it's it's more
comprehensive too so yeah definitely
check that out if you guys haven't
already
okay cupcake nation saying is at ten
point five six hmm well let's see so so
do you understand the question everyone
so basically you biked eight miles you
increased how many miles you biked the
following day by 10% then you increase
it by an additional 20 percent so do you
understand so it's basically like you
rode further the second day than you did
the first day then you bested that
second day by an additional 20% by what
percent did you increase your total
distance bike from the very first day at
eight miles do you understand that
question hmm
what do you guys think about that one is
it ten point for Caitlin saying is it
ten point five 600 you guys I'm going to
have to jump in here and see okay so
here's the thing see remember when we
were doing that problem earlier with the
sales tax with a hundred six percent see
if you're biking ten percent further how
far are you biking now 110 percent of
eight now when you use the word of what
is of me all means time so 110 percent
times eight but then you bested that
distance by an additional twenty percent
so now you're going a hundred and twenty
percent right okay all right so then
we're going to convert the percentages
to decimals so that one hundred ten
percents 1.10 one hundred twenty percent
is one point two zero and if you
multiply all that out well I'm going to
multiply these together first so what's
one point one times one point two what
do you think my cutler's turned off on
me one point one it was clear that off
one point one tie is 1.2 1.2 get a
little bit of glare in here okay so
that's one point three two you see that
one point three two
so what that means is ya Miko says one
point three - so what that means is see
this thirty two right here that means
that you increased your distance by 32%
from the original day when you're biking
so 132 percent means a 32% increase what
students will mistakenly do though
Caitlin's will say 10% plus 20% oh you
want 30% further you know what you mean
those add them together
or they'll do some other you know crazy
things that are not exactly correct
right but the key is think about one
plus ten percent right see it's a
hundred and ten percent
one plus twenty percent if you multiply
those together it's actually a hundred
and thirty-two percent of eight times Z
and that's going to give you your new
distance on that on that third day so is
that more like what you were looking for
Kalyan I hope so a little bit more
difficult percentage problem there okay
let me scroll back through the chat wee
boy this chat sir this is a live streams
running my longest that I've ever done
let's see so you guys have good
questions you're really helping each
other out I really like that everyone's
keeping it real positive I like that too
Briana's saying I took a practice test
and I didn't do so well I haven't had
math in like a year and I don't remember
anything I don't have my books to study
any advice or tips Briana check out my
huge a CT math review video course
that's what I recommend to help you
boost your score on the math section I
go through a lot of important concepts
there so that the links in the
description so check that out and you
can also check out videos on my youtube
channel
mario's math tutoring but really I try
to distill down some really important
kinds of sixty-five important classes
for the math section on the AC T so
check the link and there's some free
free previews there's three free preview
so you can see if it's something that
you're looking for let's see yeah so
let's see any other questions what else
anything you want to talk about os I
didn't see your question how many
radians will an hour hand on a clock
pass through as it rotates from 6:00
p.m. Monday to 8 a.m. Tuesday well
that's a good question so from 6 p.m.
Monday to 8 a.m. Tuesday well anybody
have any want to help with that I think
I know how to do that question but what
do you think can you guys answer asked
this question how many readings want our
hand on a clock pass through as it
rotates from 6 p.m. on Monday to 8 a.m.
on Tuesday well we know it yeah so what
do you think I'll let you guys work on
that one with 4s there Briana's asking
can you go over multiplying matrices Oh
Briana if you go back a little bit in a
live stream we actually did some
matrices so just if you scroll back you
can find out about multiply matrices
also I have my youtube channel Mario's
math tutoring just look up multiplying
matrices or type in multiplying matrices
Mario's math tutoring and you can see
how I did that so okay let's see Angela
is saying two pi radians equals one
revolution or turn that's right so
you're on the right track there angel
helping help an S out there good yeah so
one revolution is two pi radians you
have to figure out how many revolutions
you know that it's making and I'm sure
there's probably going to be a fraction
of it in there too so you have to work
work through that
so what other questions do you guys have
we're setting like a world record here
on the at least my longest live stream
what else do you want to ask me other
things you want to talk about if you're
just joining us make sure you subscribe
to the channel if you haven't already
and go over there to my YouTube page and
you can see all kinds of videos that
I've done on things to help you in your
math class and things too ok probability
and statistics Breanna is asking about
okay that's a good question yeah we can
talk about some probability if you have
again the more specific you can be like
with a specific question the more that
I'll be able to help you so if you can
ask me like a more specific question you
know like more detailed and we can do a
little bit more detailed here yeah if
you're liking this video give it a
thumbs up so I know to do more of these
let's see allegations and not sure what
that one means see what else but as far
as probability does everybody know what
the definition of probability is
probability is what it's okay all
Brianne just says someone told me to
study for the test so okay so well
here's here it is Brianna probability is
the number of successes right so we talk
about successes that's what you want
right divided by the total possible
outcomes total outcomes right so just a
simple example Brianna like you know the
thing is on the a CT I think somebody
was asking earlier like you know what's
the format of the test and how should i
do my timing and all that kind of good
stuff and the thing is is that in the
beginning of the test maybe they'll save
maybe the first 20 questions or so
they're usually pretty straightforward
they're pretty easy and so they won't
take you as much time
and so if you can get those ones done a
little bit quicker you can save some of
the time for the tougher ones that
usually come near the middle and end of
the test so it's 60 questions 60 minutes
so you have about a minute per question
so you can kind of judge but the ones in
the beginning you know you maybe only
take you 20 seconds so let's see so
we've got so basically a basic
probability question be something like
this if you have in a hat this
represents the hat here there's two red
marbles three blue marbles what's the
probability of picking a red marble use
everyone know what that is what's it
probably picking your red marble well
what do you think to read three blue you
want to pick a red so let's write this
down probability of picking a red marble
well what do you think 2/5 Dowell says
angel says 2/5 Brianna says 2/5 Miko
says two to three now Miko that's
actually the odds two chances of success
2/3 failure so success to fear that's
odds
Mason 2/5 Miko cupcake okay everyone's
right so it's to two successes out of
five total possible outcomes that's it
yeah so basically you know probability
you don't have to know to advance of a
problem the main thing is just knowing
this formula number of successes over
total possible outcomes that's the key
yeah there's two Reds out of five total
that's right so yeah so good
so what other questions other things you
want to ask about I like how you guys
are helping each other
Dario is joining us welcome Dario so
we're just going through a little Q&A
Breanna singing sohcahtoa like the sine
cosine tangent we talked a little about
that earlier Neville's saying how to
make word problems really very easy get
confused sometimes any tips or advice
yeah you always want to try to draw a
diagram and then try to write an
equation based on your diagram so I was
trying to sketch it out that's a nice
helps systems of equations problems
angels saying yeah so these are all very
good questions we did talk about some of
these earlier in the livestreams so if
you want to go back we talked about
systems of equations Mason saying and
Marina says I'll go back in the stream
after afterwards yeah so yeah
Miko's saying thank you okay good I'm
glad this helped you guys that's great
can you do a problem of plain geometry
yeah if you have more specific
questions about like if you can kind of
tell me a little bit more I appreciate
can you explain laws we talked about
dari we talked about that a little bit
earlier in the livestream if you kind of
scroll back through and you can also see
these videos on my youtube channel like
I did a whole thing on blogs you know
everything you need to know about law
because that's a really good one if you
want to check that out
my Morrow's mastering and YouTube
channel everything you need to know
about logs so if you're just joining us
right now we're just doing a little Q&A
and so if you have questions put a
detailed question in the chat I'll try
to answer it here or what's even better
everyone that's participating has been
helping each other out so that's really
good that's that's the best
so yeah Brianna's asking about triangles
how to identify the type of a triangle
whether it's acute right or obtuse that
kind of thing let's see what other
questions you guys have I'm trying to
try to focus on the ones I think that
are going to be the most helpful
let's see Abby's giving us some
equations here w x y and z has the
greatest value
Dario's saying about special triangles
okay that's a good question
Mason's have like a little system of
equations there we can talk about
special triangles a little bit if you
guys want those appear on the AC T and
some some form or another but if you're
just joining us I've been talking about
the huge AC T math review video of
course so let me just let me just talk
about it maybe one one last time here if
you're just joining us this is what you
want to check out there's a link in the
description let me just write it out
here so a link in description there's
three free previews three free previews
so you can check that out see if it's
something that you are interested in
something you think will help you and
it's called a huge a CT math review
video course okay and I go through 65
concepts okay that are important to know
for the a CT it's about three and a half
hours of course it's broken down into a
lesson per concept so if something is
easy you could skip it and focus on the
tougher ones are the ones you need more
practice with and there's a link in the
description check that out and if you're
interested in online
ring or FaceTime tutoring or you know
that kind of thing feel free to reach
out to me I know we're getting near the
end here the best thing probably at this
point to get the most efficient I
probably get the get the video course
but if somebody wanted to meet with me
online for your math class in the future
or AC T SAT tutoring you can always
reach out and contact me so this is a
this is my course here I spend a lot of
time putting this together to
specifically help students boost their
score on the huge a CT math review video
course this really boosters boost your
score on that test but let me scroll
back through the chat real quick here
and see what other questions Neville is
asking about the SAT livestream yeah you
can check out some of my other SAT live
streams I've got a lot of the official
practice tests a lot of the problems
worked out now well you can check those
out of my youtube channel Kaitlyn is
asking about parallelograms okay Haley
is asking about us okay a sphere is
inscribed in a cube okay so check this
problem out see if you guys can do this
problem looks like the sun's creeping in
here I'm getting a little bit of glare
it's a little bit harder to see okay so
we've got we've got a cube right and
there's a sphere that's inscribed inside
of that cube right and with a diagonal
of three square roots of three feet okay
so now let's see this okay what is the
diameter of the sphere okay so let's see
if we can draw this picture so there's a
sphere okay inside of here right and so
your let me see if I understand this
correctly so you're saying that this
diagonal let's see let's see so you're
saying the diagonal is 3 square root of
3 it is that right Hayley Mike do I have
this right see if you can let me know so
this is my diagram accurate what I have
here 3 square roots of 3
is that right over here and we're trying
to find the diameter well I'm going to
assume it is so basically what I'm going
to do is I'm going to draw this like
that right okay and so here's the thing
like
this side over here is is X right this
side here is X this side here is X let's
see okay and sent over here we've got X
square root of two okay so the thing is
when you have a square healy and
somebody else was asking about special
right triangles so this is important
you've got a 90 90 90 but when you draw
that diagonal it's cuts this angle in
half so this is becomes a 45-45-90
triangle okay and so then what happens
is this side is X the side as X but this
side is X root two so so hang with me
here so basically this is X root 2 but
the thing is we have to figure out what
X is because you see if you put the
sphere right inside of this cube then
we're going to get the diameter okay of
this sphere that's going to be X so what
the equation we have to solve right here
Hailie if I have this right if I don't I
think the basic idea will help it's x
squared plus X root 2 squared equals 3
square root of 3 squares I'm just using
the Pythagorean theorem a squared plus B
squared equals C squared
and so if I simplify this we get x
squared plus 2x squared cos square root
of 2 squared is just 2 and then x
squared is x squared and here we get 3
squared is 9 square root of 3 squared is
3 so that comes out to 27 so we get 3x
squared equals 27 x squared is equal to
9 and then if you take the square root
you can see that X is equal to 3 so that
means that C over here Hailie see how
this is 3 that means the diameter the
sphere is 3 so this was really just
using the Pythagorean theorem a couple
of times and also knowing the special
right triangle here the 45-45-90 to find
this diagonal the base of that cube so I
hope that helps you understand a little
bit better see Cayden says when it comes
to the SAT if you took the AC T would be
worth it to take the SAT even so when
you have two Smit okay so that's what
some of the students in the chatter are
helping Caden out with
well you know we're at we're at about
the hour-and-a-half point right now what
do you think I think you guys got a lot
of good questions in here I know I
wasn't able to get to all of them but
hopefully you guys can help answer each
other's questions in the chat you know
even after this livestream ends if you
guys want to interact with each other
and you know ask questions and help each
other out that's what the chats for so
you know go ahead and stick around even
after I leave and see if you can help
help each other out keep it positive you
know is the main thing right keep it
helpful that's the main thing but uh I
think you know at this point I'll just
kind of make one last kind of
announcement you know not only do I have
this huge a CT math review video course
but I also have one for the SAT as well
so if you go to that link in the
description you can find the video
courses and there's three free previews
for the act1 and there's three free
previews for the SAT one so check those
out see if that's something that you're
interested in sign up for those get
those courses if you think that they'll
be helpful for you and I just want to
thank everybody for just being really
positive helping each other out and if
you haven't liked this video go ahead
and give it a thumbs up if you haven't
subscribed go ahead and subscribe to the
channel and I look forward to seeing
everybody in the future videos that I do
if you want to reach out to me at any
point you know feel free to do that if
you want online tutoring we can
certainly do that but I think at this
point we'll just wrap it up and I just
want to wish everybody a good luck on
the AC T on Saturday okay so thanks a
lot and I look forward to hearing how
you did if you want to report back
sometimes that's a lot of fun just come
back to this video and let me know how
you did and I look forward to us seeing
how you guys all did so alright well
that wraps it up have a good rest of
your day and I'll talk to y'all soon all
right bye